every week public support for impeaching
Donald Trump is going up reasonable
question David why do we give you know
what about this why do we care about
this the reason we care is that if
there's any chance that Republicans will
turn on Donald Trump it's going to be
based on public opinion about
impeachment for better or worse we can
say this is terrible that this is the
reality but this is the reality
Republicans are putting their fingers to
the wind and to the extent that public
opinion shifts in favor of impeaching
and removing Donald Trump that is the
only remotely possible way that you are
going to see Republicans say you know
what maybe it is time for the president
to go it's not likely but we do have
some historical precedent for it if you
go back to the 1970s and Richard Nixon
this was admittedly historically a very
different circumstance public support
for Nixon's removal was a really big
piece of Republicans eventually going to
Nixon and saying listen we don't want to
impeach you to convict you on
impeachment but we sort of are going to
have to it would be much better if you
resigned and ultimately Nixon did resign
and that's why this is relevant so let's
look at the numbers for Donald Trump
multiple new polls about this none of
them good for Trump new Quinnipiac poll
says 55% of registered voters support
the impeachment inquiry that's up four
points from a week ago which was up from
46 the week before which was up from
like the high 30s the week before that
so the trend is very very clear
48% support not just the inquiry but the
removal of the President of the United
States that's roughly half of the
country on the question of whether
Trump's dealings with Ukraine were all
to further his personal interest 59% say
yes they were also up from previous
numbers also not good for Donald Trump
by the way as a leading indicator to
further future support for impeachment
now on that one the question to me is
why do 59% it's not a question of why
59% realized the truth about Trump's
dealing with Ukraine it's what is
preventing the other 41% from
realizing that obviously Donald Trump's
interactions with Ukraine
we're out of personal interest like what
is holding back that 41 percent from
realizing what's right in front of their
faces
also from the Quinnipiac University poll
58 percent of independents support the
inquiry 49 percent say removed Trump
from office which is absolutely stunning
we have a new reuters/ipsos poll which
shows that among independent voters
impeachment support is up it's not just
Democrats who want Trump impeached that
one says that overall 48% of the country
wants Trump impeached and removed in
line with the first poll that we looked
at and then you have a new CNN poll
which says 50 percent of Americans want
Trump removed also very high now we can
quibble about the specific numbers and
the margins for error one says 48 ones
is 49 one says 51 as a margin for error
of three the CNN poll famously has a
margin of error of five which makes it
on the border of being statistically
significant but somewhere around if you
look at all the polls on average
somewhere around one and two Americans
believe that Donald Trump should be
impeached and removed from office and
that's a number that's climbing weekly
this is not normal that's the important
thing to understand this was not the
case under Barack Obama Republicans
hated the guy Republicans talked about
impeaching Obama they didn't because
they wouldn't have been able to there
was nothing to impeach him over and
there was no public demand for the
impeachment of Barack Obama when you
look at these numbers and understand the
hyper partisan environment that exists
today 59% of the country agreeing on
anything is stunning that's why 88%
agreeing on universal firearms purchase
background checks after Sandy Hook was
so huge and still our elected officials
just couldn't get it done
so these impeachment numbers are massive
remember that the public hearings
haven't even started yet it's all just
been meetings and requests for documents
so far my guess is that the public
hearings will very heavily trigger
Donald Trump's Twitter rampages which
don't seem to be helping him lately so
we are just at the beginning of this
thing the concern though is we are now
only what is it 53 weeks
54 weeks
the 2020 election and if this is going
to damage Trump it's got to get going
before Trump's reelection campaign
really gets going in earnest and takes
over the news cycle that's where we are
right now let me know what you think
leave a comment if you're watching on
youtube send me a tweet if you're on
twitter at D Pakman today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blink Asst it's amazing it's an app for
your phone tablet or web browser and
what they do is they take nonfiction
books popular nonfiction critically
acclaimed nonfiction they condense the
book into a fifteen minute audio book
you get all the most important
information and insights from each book
but you can soak up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n